right until about two seconds ago I was
going to open up this video with a joke
about oh I wish I had a crystal ball
that way I would have known that Red
Dawn wasn't worth watching over rise of
the Guardians but I should have known
that if I didn't actually know that I
deserve to be kicked in the taint so
there that is snappy instead let's not
cry over spilled milk list now review a
movie that's been out for about four
days now better late than never
rise of the Guardians the rise of the
Guardians is pretty much like The
Avengers for kids said again I think
every kid on earth has seen the Avengers
so it's just the Avengers with the
mythological characters that bedtime
stories for kids are made from that's
more accurate namely Santa Claus the
Easter Bunny the Tooth Fairy the Sandman
and now Jack Frost is the boogeyman like
rising in power and he's like ah I'm
gonna strike fear in the hearts of
everyone how is he rising to power
because everyone's now afraid why
because he's turning their dreams into
nightmares how cuz they saw the movie
sinister about him and that's how he's
rising to power not really in the movie
but I'm just saying if it were to happen
in real life that is how so now the moon
which makes all the decisions as to
which mythological fairytale creatures
going to become a guardian makes a new
Guardian that Guardian is Jack Frost now
I really like Jack Frost any time
there's a character who's like oh yeah
I'm really not the responsibility kind
of person I'm fun I make snow days I
make snowball fights
I will shirk being a guardian for
remaining fun why because being a
guardian is all about deadlines and no
one is more awesome so I immediately
related to Jack Frost and really the
movie revolves around Jack Frost you
have the other supporting characters no
Santa Claus is big Russian Jack Frost
and the Easter Bunny don't like each
other that much it just made for a
really good mix but the movie had a
surprising amount of heart when it came
to Jack Frost or a couple times you're
like whoa okay it's not just throwing
fairytale creatures on the screen for
the sake of doing it because of like
wool that's just kind of what the movies
about so it'll be fun enough seeing the
fairy tale creatures so he's easy to
relate to and he has depth to his
character it's just a good main
character to have the 3d is really
impressive too and Jack Frost is flying
around going in betweens dog you're like
okay this is a 3d movie that shows how
3d movies can still be cool there was a
part in rise of the Guardians that made
me chuckle I was like that was funny and
I realized I was like wait a minute I
haven't really laughed in this movie
which surprised me usually a CGI kids
movie
it has a premise like this you would
expect it to be a comedy I can only say
I guess it's not a comedy it's an
adventure movie it doesn't try to be
funny because it's not there to be funny
and I felt like the end happened really
quickly it's like you know the boogeyman
has his plan and in the end it's like a
plan wrap up and it felt really quick it
was like alright this movie had a
surprising amount of depth to it a
surprising amount of layers in the end
just kind of happened and it was done
better enough dude so in the end the 3d
was great the cinematography was great
all the action scenes were really
exciting the characters were cool I love
how they interact Jack Frost was awesome
he was really relatable and I had a
surprising amount of depth and layers to
his character that made the movie just
all the more relevant should I have
watched this instead of read done
entirely mm-hmm in the end I will say I
would buy rise to the Guardians on
blu-ray it's one of those movies you
watch it as an adult and it still brings
out your inner child you're like ah man
a time when life was just more simple
right so what's your favorite childhood
movie what I mean by that is what's the
movie that you watch a lot as a kid
you're like oh I'm a kid I have a
babysitter the babysitter knew to put
that movie in to keep you planted there
so they wouldn't have to do anything for
like two hours me I'm pretty sure it was
Wrath of Khan that's just how that went
down and that was that was one of my
movies so whatever it is comment below
let me know and as always if you liked
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more
you